good afternoon I am ernesto zedillo of
the Center for the Study of
globalization thanks for being here well
exactly two years ago at on sep tember
15 2008 at one thirty in the morning it
was announced that Lehman Brothers was
going out of business and that was the
beginning of a very special period an
episode because we started I would say
you can mark with that date what is now
called the first grand crisis of the
21st century I don't think I need to
make a recollection of the events that
followed the fall of Lehman Brothers but
it's interesting to remember that only
two days after that AIG went under the
water a money market fund went also
under the water and by thursday and
friday of that week there was literally
widespread panic in not only financial
markets in the US but practically all
over the world so much that on friday of
that week the secretary of the treasury
of the united states and the chairman of
the Federal Reserve Bank of the board of
the Federal Reserve Bank of the United
States went to the White House and got
authorization from the President of the
United States to undertake unprecedented
effort to avoid the collapse of the of
the financial sector it is still took a
few weeks before they got their way with
the US Congress and during those hectic
days I think it is not an exaggeration
to say that we were on the eve of seeing
a total collapse not only of the
financial system but perhaps of the real
economy of the major economies of the
world it took a few weeks before we
could see some coherent and coordinated
action to stop or to mitigate that huge
risk of collapse but by then I think
that I much was done to a significant
extent the global economy had its worst
year in terms of GDP growth in many
decades in 60 years there was a lot of
variance but practically every major
economy suffer a lot and also a number
of emerging economies had to take
substantial pain right from the
beginning needless to say the occurrence
of this crisis was identified with
failures in the financial system it was
particularly revealing that right from
the first meeting of the g20 at the
leaders level in November of 2008 those
leaders committed strongly to undertake
coordinated action in order
to provide the world with a new
financial architecture and new financial
rules that will make the system less
vulnerable to the kind of events that we
were going through those days they
reiterated that commitment at the London
meeting of April of nine and certainly
in September of 09 at the summit in pics
were and meanwhile on the National
tracks various efforts of reform were
started at some point these efforts had
not been necessarily consistent among
themselves despite the commitment taken
by the g20 but in any case it has been
happening needless to say the most
significant of these undertakings given
the relative importance of the US
financial system is precisely the reform
that was signing to will only last July
after a long tortoise complex process of
negotiation in the US Congress for some
people well this is the reform that not
only will set a standard or other parts
of the world but that perhaps also will
prevent the occurrence of another crisis
like the one we had in 08 and that to
some extent we are still suffering today
but for others there may be questions
about the usefulness the consistency the
substance of that reform some people may
even questioned whether it was of the
highest priority to have a financial
form like the one that has been posed
considering that perhaps it was not so
much a problem in the financial sector
as a problem in the management of what
we economies like to call the global
macroeconomic imbalances believing that
without those global macroeconomic
imbalances perhaps we wouldn't have seen
those problems in the financial sector
to begin with but this is just to say
that the subject continues to be highly
controversial it will continue to be
debated but for the time being I think
it is important to pay attention to what
policymakers are deciding nowadays and
for that reason today we have put
together what I there to call a
fantastic panel of experts to discuss
the financial reform in the United
States I can hardly think of a better
group to undertake this endeavor because
we have with us of course our very own
professor Bob Shiller and when people
speak about this crisis I think there
are less than three experts that came we
pointed out as persons that saw it
coming somehow and and one of them of
course was professor Bob chiller and I
don't need to go through his very long
biography because all of us know about
his very important work we also have
with us and I thank him a lot for making
the journey the long journey from New
York City a professor Tom Cooley who
until recently was Dean of the stern of
school school of business and anyway
in were you but more importantly for our
purposes he has been an intellectual
leader at Eastern school of a group that
in a very lucid and timely fashion has
been following events of course before
the crisis but particularly relevant
during the crisis and after the crisis
this group at NYU with an incredibly
opportunity produce a mayor work which
is titled restoring financial stability
how to repair a faith system I think
they got together in the fall of eight
and already early 09 they had produced
this incredible volume and even more
surprising is that a few weeks after the
signing of the bill the financial reform
bill they had produce another book which
is already available somehow but it will
be published in print within a few days
which is called regulating Wall Street
the new architecture of global finance
which also has a fantastic collection
papers so Tom Cooley is with us today
and then with us we have one of our
newest acquisitions we have a steep road
hardly need any introduction because he
has been a very visible economic
influential analyst for a long time he
used to be as chairman of Morgan Stanley
Asia he just retired and with very good
judgment he decided to accept
appointment both at the school of
management here and also at the soon to
be presented Jackson Institute and the
reason why I thought it was great to
have a steep here
is because he was also among the very
few who saw it coming I remember to have
been with Steve in places strength
places like Moscow Beijing Barcelona
before the crisis many places and steve
was always speaking about the crisis to
come you know and I remember that people
sometimes say what is this guy talking
about what crisis he's talking about
well unfortunately steve was right and
so i think is very fortunate now he is
part of our community and probably this
is one of the first public appearances
that steved us at our university so
having said that and let's go to the
real to the real work and i will ask bob
keeler to open
okay Thank You Ernesto so we're talking
about the new dodd-frank bill I also
want to add the new Basel three
agreement that just came out there's a
lot of information this is a major
turning point in our financial system
let me first say that I'm much more warm
and positive to Dodd and Frank than most
my economist colleagues I think it's
amazing what they did given what their
background was there not PhD economist I
think we would have had a better bill if
we put John John accomplice Gary Gorton
and members of this panel on writing the
bill Barney Frank was a dropout from a
poli-sci PhD program he's pretty smart
though if you look at the bills they
take account of the problems the bill
take account of the issue it seems like
they've listened to a lot of people and
but I don't think that Congress can
resolve the difficult questions so
unfortunately the dodd-frank bill seems
to be very strong on setting up new
agencies and ordering the agencies to
study something and then decide and it
seems to me that the outcome of this
will it will be depends on what those
people do and we don't know yeah I think
that it's all most of it is to come but
i do want to congratulate Dodd and Frank
I think they did well we don't have a
dysfunctional Congress at least in terms
of this bill so so Ernesto points out
today is the second anniversary of the
lehman brothers bankruptcy I wanted to
do a thought experiment and ask what
would have happened regarding this
bankruptcy if dodd-frank had been put in
place let's say a full ten years ago so
I could have all worked out now i have
to say i don't know what exactly would
have happened because dodd-frank as i
said as a plan for future studies and
the like but i'm going to try to imagine
so the the dodd-frank bill creates
something called the financial services
Oversight Council which is supposed to
be preventing sis
failure making recommendations to
government regulators to prevent crises
and it's going to be headed by the
Treasury secretary now this sounds like
a bit is potentially a big and important
change but I do have some little
questions about it I kind of remember
back in 1987 President Reagan set up
something called the president's working
group on financial markets it became
nicknamed the plunge team and they were
supposed to prevent systemic crises and
it had the Treasury secretary I forget
who else it's kind of a similar event
they didn't do much yes and they didn't
prevent this crisis so let's go back to
2000 the Treasury Secretary was Larry
Summers okay he is famous for at a
Jackson Hole conference chastising
raghav rajan for claiming that there's
an instability in the economy and so I
kind of doubt that Larry Summers was in
the mood to do the kinds of things that
fsoc is supposed to do but I wanted to
go on with other Treasury secretaries
and the net who is the next Treasury
secretary do you remember Paul O'Neill
who was a former CEO of Alcoa the
aluminum producing company by the way
not as far as I know an econ PhD and he
was replaced under bush by Jon Snow who
was the CEO of CSX railroad okay these
are the guys who are supposed to be
doing these steps to prevent this crisis
it's going to then we got Henry Paulson
who knew a little bit more about finance
apparently but this is what is supposed
to happen the FSOC is supposed to
remember that the Lehman Brothers is not
a bank it owned the bank called Lehman
Brothers bank but it was tiny is only
five billion dollars that bank by the
way still survives they got spun off
from that the owner that died and the
bank guess what they did the first thing
they did
to change their name but no I called the
Aurora bank now but they're okay but
Lehman Brothers was not a bank so it
didn't have bank regulation and it
didn't have the Fed regulating now this
is the critical thing in dodd-frank
Lehman Brothers was a investment bank
which is not a commercial bank so dodd
frank says that the FOS FSOC here on a
two-thirds vote designated as a to be
regulated by the Fed but only if they if
the council determines i'm reading from
the bill from the act if the council
determines that material financial
distress it of the u.s. non-bank
financial company could pose a threat to
the financial stability of the united
states ok so ten years ago would this
have happened or any time in the last
decade would the Treasury secretary have
announced that Lehman Brothers poses a
threat to the financial stability of the
United States and so should be regulated
by the federal reserve I want to point
out that LeMans debt was rated A+ by
Standard & Poor's until june of two
thousand eight which was like a few
months before their bankruptcy now so
what will happen will the FSOC put it in
order to make this work they've got to
put a lot of companies like Lehman
Brothers that look perfectly sound under
the under the direction of the FSOC I
can go on and on here running is where
we're talking about a thousand page bill
and it there's so much going on that I
can't but I don't I think that it all
depends on what the who we put in charge
of the FSOC and how aggressive they are
and how much they understand what's
going on now John John accomplice is
sitting right in front of me has made a
very convincing case that there is a
sort of leverage cycle that drives
economies so we get and this has been
backed up by other route so for example
Reinhart and Rogoff was shown the
leverage builds up in booms and then it
over and then it tends to collapse and
it produces bad periods that go for a
long time so what's in the bill
regarding this well I see in the in the
act is now an act it says I have it here
somewhere but I'm taking too much time
to find it that the it is essentially
the language is something like if the
Fed now regulating Lehman Brothers or
someone like that determines that the
company is a grave threat to the US
economy it can impose a 15 to 1 leverage
ratio something like that I've been
trying to find it here and will they do
that I don't know that that's that's the
question Basel 3 is in interposing as
well that's an international agreement
that also talks a lot about leverage and
this there's so many ideas here I don't
know where let me just jump ahead cuz I
don't want to monopolize this whole
thing just concluding from what I've
said that I give credit to Dodd and
Frank and all the other people for
taking note of I think they've listened
to you John and they've listened to Gary
Gordon and they don't know what to make
of it so they said these people are
smart they might be right so let's
commission of study let's create they
created the office of financial research
now I was wondering that's under the
FSOC that could be a big thing if they
fund it at a high enough level you know
we could have 10,000 economists they're
researching financial stability so i
looked at does it say how big it will be
and maybe I missed something but it says
something like the Treasury Secretary
shall confer with someone and they'll
decide on a budget so we don't know the
fs the Office of Financial Research
could turn out to be John John
accomplice and a thousand GM ba is
working under him or it could be me and
two MBAs or who knows what we just don't
know and but it's that the bill is a one
to go
I would that would be an important job
but anyway then the other say
it would it would be hard to turn that
down I suppose the I mentioned that the
credit rating given to Lehman Brothers
was a plus something was wrong there ok
well the bill has a whole section on
credit rating agencies and it does all
has all kinds of ideas how to prevent
this from making making headway but I
read the whole thing I haven't read it
yeah maybe is sympathetically as I could
but it has things in it like the there's
a title saying information from sources
other than the issuer basically the
credit rating agency is required by law
now not to rely entirely on the issuer
there's a lot of little things like that
that are in the bills that that might
I'm just going to mention a few because
I think I'm out of time here but just a
couple other things executive
compensation this is a political hot
potato and part of the problem is that
our system of executive compensation may
reward inappropriate risk-taking so you
think you're right now let's say I'm CEO
of Lehman or some company like that
everybody knows the government's going
to bail me out so hey I'm a riskless I
can borrow at the riskless rate so why
don't I borrow at the riskless rate and
leverage myself up in risky assets and
at 50-50 chance of I'll make it and I'll
be rich or I go bankrupt and then you
know nothing happens to me so we want to
sort of consider some kind of change in
compensation structure that might change
their incentive to take these risks and
there is there's a whole bunch of things
in this bill there is something about
preventing incentive based payment
arrangements that it doesn't say just
for the Fed it says the federal
appropriate federal regulators can
prohibit pay arrangements that create
the wrong incentives so actually I wrote
a New York Times column advocating
something that I have belonged to a
group called a squam lake group and we
had many recommendations but one of our
recommendation I know Tom Cooley has
recommendations on executive
compensation that are kind of similar in
a way but our recommendation is that
executives that systemically important
firms should have part of their salary
held back it should be a law you you
can't take all your salary up front and
you'll only get it like five years later
and you won't get it if the government
bailed you out so it feels a penalty for
being bailed out so I wrote a New York
Times column about that and then to my
amazement Barney Frank called me two
days later he's just on the phone he
just calls me up you know he's not very
ceremonious there's no secretary he just
calls me up and he said I liked your
column and he said I think it's in our
bill already and he said well I think
it's there but I don't want to change
the wording now because it's too late
but I found the passage that he was
referring to and it just says that that
regulators can prohibit prohibit
incentive-based payments and Barney has
invited someone from our group of to a
hearing on this so it seems like we do
have a functional Congress they have
ideas they're listening to academics but
they're still groping and maybe the
other thing is a huge section in the
bill about mortgage reform and there's
also a consumer financial product safety
commission I think it's a good bill but
I think I'll stop with it and I'll say
that it's only good to the extent that
we make it good and it seems to me that
it has enough in it that if we get the
right people and we and we respect
people who studied and thought about
these things they can transform the
dodd-frank bill into something that
really does help prevent this kind of
crisis thank you
professor Cooley well thank you very
much I want a second one of Bob's
recommendations at write to your
Congressman and nominate John Jenna
Coppola speed the head of the Office of
Financial Research and that the end
result of that this bill will be a lot
better than you might now expect there I
want to also start with a little
shameless advertising there's a book
forthcoming book called regulating Wall
Street by myself and forty of my closest
friends it's two in stores soon bye I
think October twelfth something like
that you can order now on amazon and it
explains all two thousand three hundred
plus pages of the dodd-frank act and
simple easy to understand terms just
getting i mean i've i've read all two
thousand three hundred pages of the act
and i understand quite a few of them so
but as Bob said there's a lot still to
be determined in the way the act is
implemented so there's an enormous
amount of rulemaking yet to be done
there I believe something like 112 rules
that are yet to be written there are
sixty studies that have to be completed
before we know how exactly this is going
to change the landscape of regulation
now the dodd-frank act is widely
described as the most ambitious attempt
to to change financial regulation
regulation of financial system since the
1930s and I agree with that assessment
it's the most ambitious the question
is does it have a chance at being as
successful as reforms that were put in
place in the 1930s the 1930s was sort of
a watershed in US economic history and a
watershed in regulatory history and for
whatever reason by accident by design by
just good luck the reforms that were put
in place in the 1930s gave us one could
easily argue you know seven decades of
relatively good financial performance
our economy our financial system was the
envy of the world and so did that happen
because these were well-designed
regulations or did it happen simply
because we were in the sweet spot in
terms of economic growth following World
War two there are a lot of a lot of
possible explanations for that and so
one thing you can do is you can ask the
question what made those reforms
successful and you can go back to the
simple economic theory of regulation and
ask you know why why did these things
succeed they succeeded because they
identified externalities in the
financial system asymmetric information
problems moral hazard problems and they
addressed them with regulations that
specifically targeted those failures of
the financial system so the the famous
glass-steagall act was one such thing
the creation of the FDIC the creation of
the SEC all of these targeted specific
market failures in the financial system
and as a result and then they addressed
the likely feedback of the regulations
on things like moral hazard and so on by
putting in place further constraints on
financial activities so the question is
over time what happened well over time
what happened is that the world evolved
financial markets evolved banks that
began to eat away at the edges of these
regulation the process of regulatory
arbitrage began to render the
regulations ineffective and attempts to
patch up the system by say the Basel one
embezzle to capital Accords were
disaster because the banks very quickly
used those those rules as opportunities
for regulatory arbitrage and what
happened is what grew out of that is a
parallel financial intermediation system
the shadow banking system and the shadow
banking system was not subject to the
rules of the game and the same way that
deposit based banking systems had been
and without taking you through the whole
litany of the financial crisis and and
the stories that led up to sep tember 15
2008 you can easily recall what it was
that happened and why things got out of
control so with that as a preamble what
do I think of the dodd-frank act well
the real story tempted to answer that
question you have to begin with an
analysis of what caused the failure what
caused the collapse and they were in my
view and ma cording to me and my
co-authors it was a result of the build
up of systemic risk in the financial
system that is risk that in which
individual firms act
Jones had consequences for the whole
financial Commons and there was also
kind of an undermining of the regulatory
system that had that had been put in
place to to deal with that and there was
a growth of this parallel banking system
so I don't want to take up too much time
I'll be relatively brief but what do I
think of the dodd-frank act well I think
I agree with Bob I think it's a it's an
amazing thing that this complicated act
got through the enormously difficult
political process and that and that you
know Barney Frank and Christopher Dodd
managed to keep their ducks in a row and
muster sufficient support to get this
thing passed there's a lot to be still
determined what I will say about it is
that in some sense its heart is in the
right place that is it recognizes the
central importance of systemic risk of
systemic risks in the financial system
and it tries to identify tries to
address that by the aforementioned
systemic risk council that's going to
deal with systemically important
institutions by giving the Federal
Reserve new powers to address
systemically risky institutions and to
regulate them and by providing for
things like orderly liquidation of
systemically important institutions by
providing by requiring them to prepare
funeral plans so that they can engage in
an orderly demise if you like and so it
tries to put in place a lot of put back
in place a lot of things
that were were effective in the 1930s at
containing this these kinds of risks it
has a lot of pieces to it that are
essentially irrelevant to the smooth
functioning of the financial system I
would argue that the things we can get
into the details of why I think this but
as issues of executive compensation and
consumer protection a lot of that stuff
has not as not really central to the
stability of the financial system so it
goes a long way towards making the
system safer it has sections on capital
requirements which say that whatever
comes out of the basal process the u.s.
is going to stick to strict capital and
liquidity requirements it has a very
good section on regulating derivatives
contracts which ensures a greater deal
of transparency and more easily more
easy resolution of positions in the
event of financial collapse and so on so
so what don't I like about it if its
heart is in the right place well one is
that it basically fails to ask the
question that you should ask at the
beginning which is what is banking and
what is a bank it's designed to regulate
by form rather than function so there's
far too much of an emphasis on deposit
based banking institutions without a
recognition without enough of a
recognition there's some recognition
that a lot of the problems that caused
this financial crisis came from the fact
that the shadow banking system evolved
in in parallel to the deposit base
system and a lot of the instability and
a lot of the problems arose there there
are problems in the repo markets and
there are many issues that are just
simply not addressed now it does say
that the Fed has the ability to
designate systemically risky
institutions that are not banks that are
not deposit based banks but at the same
time it severely limits what is called
the feds 13-3 lending authority which is
what it appealed to when it bailed out
Bear Stearns would have had to appeal to
had it bailed out Lehman Brothers so
what it says is that the Fed can
designate systemically risky non-bank
firms it can appeal to this systemic
risk council and that I was sobered by
Bob's account of some of our recent
Treasury secretaries thinking about them
dealing with it evidently Paul O'Neill
was most concerned at the Treasury with
the up boxes that were piled in the
hallway because he was a big worker
safety and I remember actually him
saying to me at some point why does it
take us so damn long to close the books
at alcoa we used to close the books with
him yeah the first company they're
reporting to flutter yeah so so that
that's a sobering prospect right you
don't want to be waiting for for
something like that for him to conduct a
worker safety inspection well Bear
Stearns is melting down so so it's it's
excessively focused on institutions and
not the financial Commons it still it
talks about systemic risk it talks about
orderly liquidation plans and so on but
it's firm by firm bank by Bank no
recognition of the system there is a
recognition of systemic risk but there's
nothing in the bill that would
discourage firms from creating this kind
of risk so if you're an economist
immediately when you think of an
externality that firms like that are
creating by their actions the immediate
tool for resolving that that comes to
mind are what we call Peruvian taxes
that is tax them / engaging in this
activity that's creating risks are
imposing costs on people who are firms
that are not parties to their
transactions and thereby discourage
those kinds of activities the other and
that's just completely missing the great
the end results of the great debate
about what was called the bank tax was
that the cost of society of resolving a
systemic ly important firm that goes
bust are to be borne by the surviving
firm's rather than born ex ante by all
the firms now that's like you know
charging the neighbors for the fire
department and the cost of fighting the
fire in your house you know when you're
barbecuing in the living room you know
this makes no sense and it imposes costs
on surviving institutions at exactly the
time that they're likely to be weakest
and most vulnerable so these are some of
the serious defects of the Act I mean I
think it has the the possibility to make
the world a little bit safer but it has
some serious serious flaws in its
thinking about these
orton issues and now the important
exercise that is I think the one that
bob was talking about that is you think
about if this act had been in place in
two thousand or two thousand three what
would have happened as the financial
crisis began to unfold would it have
stopped or mitigated the crisis the
answer is by and large I think no might
have mitigated a bit Bear Stearns would
not have been eligible for lending by
the Fed because bear stearns was not a
bank once again its regulation by form
rather than function lehman brothers
would not have been eligible now what
the new Act does say is that they could
appeal to Treasury secretary think Paul
O'Neill they could they could designate
an entire industry at risk and provide
lending facilities that apply to the
whole industry so things that they did
to rescue money market funds would be
would be perfectly valid under the
dodd-frank act and so there is a
mechanism in place that would have
stopped stopped runs on some some money
market funds I think but it would not
have stopped to run on Bear Stearns it
would not have stopped the run on Lehman
Brothers and you know the the outcome
eventually would have been if probably
if this act had been in place the
financial crisis would have gotten more
severe earlier then waiting for the
Lehman collapse it would have we'll just
started with Bear Stearns that's my take
and then a final criticism a final thing
to at least think about the act is is
this one of the most important to two of
the most important institutions in the
shadow banking system the most systemic
Lee important institutions one of the
generators of a huge risk in the economy
that are still costing us money to bail
them out we're fannie and freddie and
the acts as absolutely nothing about
them as nothing nothing to say about
what to do about housing now we've been
promised an answer about what we're
going to do about those soon but it
remains to be seen so I'll stop there
firms deep ernesta before I offer my
brief remarks in the interest of full
disclosure contrary to rumors i have not
retired from Morgan Stanley I'm still
working at Morgan Stanley I'm there a
couple days a week three days a week at
Yale maybe one day I'll retire from
Morgan Stanley but sick baby there's no
well well fine we'll find that out
shortly so you know as I it's important
for me to tell you that because you know
you you can you can evaluate my my
perspective on the basis of of the seat
or the seats that i inhabit as well
although as Ernesto did say I've not
been bashful about offering some
critical remarks of markets and market
participants in my my long career I do
remember this date two years ago
actually if I go back to a couple of
days before that on friday i think
September the 12th our stock at Morgan
Stanley closed at $45 share and it was
down a lot from the highs in the in the
low 70s earlier that summer we were
feeling pretty depressed and then 48
hours later hit an intraday low of six
and it's now bounced all the way back to
27 so you know two years later I don't
think shareholders of financial services
firms are feeling particularly a warm
and fuzzy about
the post-crisis climate I like the the
exercise that Bob took us through I
think it's very helpful I think the the
real question I would put it somewhat
differently though and that is will this
type of legislation prevent the next
crisis that that's what it's supposedly
all about I think it's important to go
back and do the experiment to see how it
had done this time and but I think what
we're really after is is getting a
mechanism in place that would never
would certainly not allow something like
this to happen again in the future and
if somebody who's lived through a lot of
financial crises as a Wall Street
participant in in my 30-plus years in
the business and having participated in
a number of post-crisis post-mortem rule
writing exercises the one thing that I
always draw from these exercises and
dodd-frank is a case in point is that we
always come up with rules and
regulations that are highly conditioned
by the crisis we've just gone through
and yet it's it's human nature and Bob
and his great work on behavioral finance
and animal spirits can tell you better
than anyone that the next crisis has
never liked the last one and so you know
we may have done a terrific job and and
it's not clear to me we have but it just
just grant the possibility we did a
terrific job in preventing the next
subprime crisis the odds of having
another subprime crisis are probably not
very high at this point
in time I also find it interesting that
the same Congress that was able to get
this agreement signed into law with
under enormous pressure from the White
House is also the same Congress that
empowered something called the fcic the
financial crisis inquiry commission that
is due to report I believe December of
this year on what actually caused the
crisis so it maybe it's ironic or
perhaps foolish for the same legislative
authority to have offered up a bill
that's designed to fix the crisis that
they don't know what caused it it's to
me you know i agree with with with bob
it was an amazing political undertaking
but it's max an awful lot of of high
high powered political theater in an
important election year and again just
to echo the point that that Bob and Tom
have both made and that is this is it's
pretty mature to judge whether or not
this bill is going to work effectively
since so much of it is yet to be
determined it's a framework and far be
it for me to prejudge the the ultimate
framework what I would like to just
offer in my one comment that I would
like to leave you with this afternoon
and that is even if this were the
perfect mousetrap I would argue that
regulatory reform is a necessary but not
sufficient condition to prevent the next
crisis from
during the missing leg to the stool in
my opinion is the failure of our
legislative authorities to address the
horrific flaws in the conduct of
monetary policy in the United States we
have had a bubble prone central bank in
the United States really since the mid
to late 1990s and it's I can assure you
it's not getting any better today we
have a central bank chairman and I don't
mean to make this personal but you have
to sort of you know talk about the man
his body of research and the papers that
he's presented in Ben Bernanke who
simply does not believe that monetary
policy should be used in any way
whatsoever to address asset bubbles and
the way in which they distort and
ultimately can affect the real side of
the US economy he did research on this
prior to coming into the Fed he's
written papers on it speeches on it and
he had a major influence on his
predecessor who certainly believed very
much in the same thing my my view and I
for those of you who read some of the
things that I've written over the years
I sound like a broken record but I'll
just run the risk of breaking the record
one more time I think monetary policy in
the US has been far too accommodative
for far too long the real federal funds
rate
the nominal funds rate adjusted for
inflation has been below its long-term
average I think for about nine of the
past ten years it's been negative or
below zero where it is right now for
more than half that time this is the
most accommodative monetary policy that
the US Federal Reserve is run since the
mid-1970s and if though for those of you
remember the 70s that was not a
particularly a good period of time the
the US central bank has had a view for a
long time that monetary policy is a
blunt instrument should not be used to
lean against asset bubbles because after
all no one ever really knows if there's
an asset bubble and it takes too big a
toll on the broad economy to use a blunt
instrument even if you did know what an
asset bubble is I honestly think that's
self-serving gobbledygook the idea that
we didn't know that there was a bubble
in equities or property or credit I mean
I realized there were probably a few
people in America who didn't read one of
your books Bob but it was it was pretty
widely distributed and and and you were
very prominent in warning of these
series of bubbles well ahead of time but
you were not alone there were others and
there was a debate on this but it was
pretty clear at the end of the 1990s as
well as the end of the property bubble
or if you're looking at credit spreads
that something was seriously awry in the
conduct of monetary policy that was
providing the type of liquidity that was
fueling these bubbles the Fed says in
response well if we had leaned against
these bubbles we would have taken a toll
on a larger portion of the economy than
we would have liked what is I think
particularly striking was at their peaks
in sort of the 2006 to 2007 period the
two bubble affected sectors of the
United States economy home building
activity and bubble distorted personal
consumption activity collectively added
up to seventy seven percent of the u.s.
GDP I mean this is what you have a blunt
instrument to address you had nearly
eighty percent of the economy distorted
by bubbles that were fueled by
irresponsibly accommodative monetary
policy so I think we need to fix that
and I think we need to add financial
stability to as a another dimension of
the Fed's policy mandate and I think the
Fed should be held explicitly
accountable towards setting monetary
policy not just with respect to full
employment as it was empowered to do in
the employment act of nineteen forty six
not as it was then amended to aim for
price stability as it was required to do
in the humphrey-hawkins act of a
nineteen seventy eight after the Great
Inflation but now in the aftermath of
the great crisis and recession I think
it's equally important to add financial
stability to the Fed's policy mandate
the Fed says oh don't worry we've
learned the lesson trust us we would
never do this again with all due respect
and as somebody has great personal
fondness for an institution that gave me
my first job at a grad school I don't
trust the Fed in this regard I think
they need to be held explicitly
accountable for financial stability as
well and and I think is part of that
they need like other central banks they
don't like doing this is a tough thing
for the staff to do they need to as part
of their accountability and financial
stability produce their own financial
stability report on a regular basis so
that they're very transparent in the way
they understand the linkage between
monetary policy and financial stability
we need to hardwire the
requirement into the system I think
that's the main point that I wanted to
make or NESN I just would finish with a
couple of other little caveat to think
your point on global imbalances that you
mentioned the outset is very important
and you know this is one of these lofty
highbrow discussions that takes place in
g20 circles and you know if you think
that you know the Paul O'Neill and Jon
Snow were out of their element in in
discussing systemic risk you ought to
sit in on one of these g20 meetings and
and listen to them talk about global
imbalances so I think we need you know
probably greater expertise in
understanding this very destabilizing
mix of global savings right now and the
role that has played in fostering this
crisis and then let me just wade into
something that I'm probably going to
regret even speaking about given where I
have worked and where I'm still working
part time and in light of what has
previously been said and this is on the
executive compensation issue I realize
this is a very inflammatory issue it's a
very sort of high charged a populist
issue especially an election year and
there's a perception that these you know
rich Wall Street guys have been ripping
off the little guy for a long time and
you know I well remember i was working
in asia and my wife sent me a she
forwarded to me an email flyer that she
had received a new tour operator we live
in New Canaan was giving tours of the
homes of AIG executives in fairfield
county so you know like these are the
lynch mobs who want to get the overly
comp
sated financial services executives all
I can speak about is my own experience
in working for one financial services
firm for 28 years we have a brutal
compensation system and as a result of
the the trading losses that Morgan
Stanley took in late a 2008 all of the
traitors who were involved in those
positions have been fired all of their
supervisors and managers have been
replaced or asked to resign the stock
holders for all the Securities and all
the employees have the bulk of their net
worth in the shares most of them are not
involved in the activities their net
worth is down an average of about fifty
percent in terms of their cash holdings
and their optioned holdings which
account for about another third to forty
percent of net worth are worthless I'm
not saying that you should weep for Wall
Street but the idea that there's no
accountability on compensation for
making a trading mistakes banking
mistakes or other mistakes and that
could be addressed by having some type
of claw back or other new compensation
caps or procedures i think is
questionable and I think the mistakes
that are trading desk made and they were
made by a few rather than a lot
unfortunately would have been made under
almost any compensation structure that i
have seen proposed so i think this is
one of these populist politically
charged fixes that is that has an awful
lot of support and appeal but one that
is not effective but the the point that
i would like to close on is again
dodd-frank necessary but not sufficient
addressed mainly at
the crisis that has occurred it's not
clear that it will be effective in
addressing the next crisis and there
will be a next crisis until we get I
think a new thinking and design for
monetary policy in the United States
thank you well before we open the floor
for some questions let me see if there
is any comment from one of the
presenters to another one of the
presenters from familia I just wanted to
say something at the Sun yeah about
since all three of us raised the issue
of compensation I want to say something
about that I bet i think you know it's
not it's not true that compensation had
no role in the financial crisis i don't
think it was necessarily central to it
but it certainly paid or played a role
in building up systemic risk on the
balance sheet of these banks and the
best demonstration of that was at ubs
and UBS commissioned a study I think by
I think was done by McKinsey but they
hired some consultants to say you know
how did how did we end up with all this
garbage on our balance sheet and the
study gives a very clear account of how
the compensation incentives of traders
and people on trading desks gave them
big rewards for basically operating this
internal carry trade their cost of funds
is low they could buy these
mortgage-related securities that produce
the yield put them on the books
warehouse them and treat the Empress
differential as profit which we all know
it's not there
you know not in some real sense but then
add that to the pool on which their
compensation was base the other thing i
want to say so so it definitely was a
culprit was that a major culprit i don't
know i'm not so sure but Bob chillers
analysis was exactly right but it didn't
go far enough so what he said is that we
need to reform compensation because even
though shareholders and executives
interests are aligned such that
executives are rewarded for taking
bigger risks because they know and the
shareholders know that there is this
implicit guarantee out there that
they'll be rescued they're too big to
fail there's a too big to fail insurance
guaranty that kicks in and so that
pushes them in the direction you know
they have lower cost of capital pushes
them to take greater risks but the
solution to that part of the solution
may be to have clawbacks and things like
that but the real solution to that is to
price those guarantees you have to price
the insurance guarantees that are out
there in the economy you have to price
too big to fail guarantees you have to
price access to lender of last resort
the chart charge you know the FDIC that
in its original conception was an
insurance captain you paid a price based
on your riskiness so so something like
that I think it can be measured and it
can be priced but we're too afraid to do
that yeah I should just recall that in
reference to this incident at Jackson
Hole where Robert Ryan was vilified and
by somebody I mean precisely the point
that Raghu was making in that
paper is that there was there were
perverse or wrong incentives in the
compensation structure of financial
institution and I think at least in the
context that he described that he was
right on the other hand is the point
that it was mentioning you know and the
story that Raghu said that you know
these people are having a are making a
one side BTW which they cannot lose and
they can win a lot but proved wrong
because the lehman brothers guys got
their network totally wipe out I think
it was Acharya from your school who said
they were like you know not only
throwing bombs to a crowd but they ran
towards the crowd because they invested
their own money in the garbage that they
were originating and securitizing try to
say something about the comment that the
Fed should be hardwired to worry about
systemic issues my first thought was
that's already in the in the bill
because the Fed is a member of the
Financial Services Oversight Council
which is defined as having a systemic
objective and the Treasury the way that
FSOC works is to then delegate authority
to the Fed for these firms that are risk
grave risks to the economy to regulate
but I think you're right that this
doesn't quite do it creating a meeting
on a half no meet once a month all these
heads of the F the Fed and the Treasury
and the FDIC will get together in some
meeting that's not the same thing as
having the Fed have its mission
redefined as having the authority and
responsibility for dealing with systemic
crises and I think that someone has to
be responsible and has it as the main
mission so and also the central bank is
the logical that we have a tradition of
almost 100 years
and other countries even longer for the
central bank having maybe some
responsibility for systemic risks and so
it seems to me more natural it would
have been more natural to do what you
said and what the dodd-frank bill said
let me just clarify that is a member of
course they wanted to run this committee
but they're they're now part of a
process that presumably will deal with
systemic risk in the narrow sense the
relationships between one institution
what I'm after is is something that is
actually broader than that as the
monitor the basic monetary policy tool
the overnight lending rate be set in a
way that is much more aligned with broad
financial stability objectives in the
United States remember you are kind of
two semi galley proof severe the first
edition of your book irrational
exuberance my memories correctly
published a few days before the Nasdaq
bubble burst in March of two thousand
and then you sent me approach to the
second edition that handed in a chat
so you don't have to keep interest in
it's a Treasury bond bubble next right
that's happening right now okay let's
have some questions or comments from the
audience and let me start here okay get
the microphone I think it's on
globalization is sponsoring this because
puzzle of course deals with a global
solution to to the regulatory situation
so I'd like to hear the panelists maybe
sort of comment perhaps on the the
proposal that was released over the
weekend and the fact that we've got
until effectively 2023 for all of the
the implementation to come through and
get the right capital rules in place
that seems to me an enormous period of
time within which we could have
countless more crises and in the context
of that I'd also like to sort of address
if you could address Steve's point about
the Fed because it seems to me that if
you had very strong capital rules and
you had leverage ratios and you dealt
with the systemic problems through the
regulatory framework then the Fed could
actually get away from the business of
having to worry about the financial
sector and focus on the economy it seems
to me that that would be another way
addressing that so I just like to anyone
who'd like to comment on that and sort
of specifically talk about perhaps the
buzzle proposal thank you well the Basel
Committee looked at
a lot of studies about what how to make
the system more resilient and what I've
seen emphasized in the press reports
I've read about it is that they're going
to a day with the Pella capital
conservation buffer to the capital stock
requirements for banks and if so the
problem is with capital requirements is
that they start being violated in bad
times and so asking banks to rebuild
their capital in a bad time is exactly
backwards so that's why you need a
buffer and the buffer when you're
violating the buffer then your
activities become limited so it's a good
idea and that on top of that they've
added another counter-cyclical buffer
that regulators can add at a time when
the economy is overheated and with the
second buffer that again requires banks
to raise more capital in good times when
it's imposed so these are clever ideas
now there's other ideas that I belong to
the squam lake group and we were talking
about contingent capital requirements
and I know that people at the financial
stability board also in Basel were
studying me but I haven't seen that
these were recommended at this at this
time it's also in dodd-frank again in
the usual dodd-frank way a study will be
commissioned of contingent capital
requirements and then the appropriate
regulators will have the power to impose
them something like that so I think some
good ideas still haven't been adopted it
seems like we're going part way Basel 3
is an improvement but there are still
more ideas that will help but this is
exactly the kind of systemic thinking
that you that you were saying that it is
true that the bill kind of focuses on
individual banks and it doesn't say much
about looking at the aggregate leverage
ratio maybe jaan jee jaan jaan
lakopolous would have something to say
about that it says something again it
banks that have a grave threat to the
econ
he would might have a leverage ratio
managed differently by regulators it
it's not it's not an inspirational
proposal in that form but maybe it will
evolve into something and there's still
hearings there's going to be more
development of these ideas I think that
I was trying to puzzle on Monday why
bank stocks european bank stocks went up
because if basile three were really
binding none these folks you would
expect the rate of return on equity is
going to fall you know credits going to
be tighter but then you look at the time
horizon and I think it reflected a great
sigh of relief that it wasn't going to
bite anytime soon you know is I one of
the things I worry about it is that
these kind of global Accords about
capital requirements are good idea in
principle but our past experience with
them if you take basil too it's just a
miserable failure indeed you could even
argue that it played a big role in in
the financial crisis and if there's a
long time before these capital
requirements become have some bite then
there's a long time to engage in
regulatory arbitrage and what happened
in the with basil too is exactly that so
they still focus on one firm at the time
that one firm at a time has enough
capital and they still use risk
weighting of assets to some degree a
little little more strict than than in
the past but you know it's it's it
doesn't seem like the
the ultimate solution now in the
dodd-frank act what they said about
capital requirements was that they were
going to put in more stringent capital
requirements and that they would treat
whatever as the basil 3 process came up
with as a possible lower bound for what
capital requirements could be so they
they were fully aware of all the
problems and politically and and in
terms of lobbying and pressure that the
basil process has inherently in it and
they said we're going to be tougher than
that most likely and boards I'm good
saying let's go through the microphone
to you want to have management and
boards on the same side as the
regulators there's has to be something
some incentive other than claw back and
and monetary considerations what do you
think about the possibility of jail time
I mean the fear not yet not not that
anybody wants to see it happen but
that's the only that's the only fear
that will put them on the same side
define it better than that but I think
in the in the in the bill there is a
provision which is much stronger than
any previous provision establishing the
responsibility and the liability of
directors of financial institutions
beyond what is already stated in the
status of the SEC whether that will make
the directors to be more serious about
their job I don't know but that's mean
but in the bill if you read that part
carefully sadly I don't have a life I
read that part of Bill carefully there's
a lot of talk about rules of
construction and what the rules of
construction say very clearly is that
you know there's been this law in rule
in the US that has kept its a tongue
it's a rule that solves a problem of
time consistency it says if directors
make decisions that are based on their
best business judgment even though they
turn out to be lousy you can't you can't
penalize them for you can't sue them you
can't send them to jail and that's
that's still going to be the rule that
governs corporate directors the Delaware
yeah Delaware
was aware that was your question what I
think is it is very hard to create a
criminal code for violation of systemic
risk standards
the job Bob said he would be going to
take as the director for this research
council when you design these metrics
and maybe they can be codified in there
could be penalties for violating nothing
right now no and the blue shirt
pretty much I i'm thinking of two
aphorisms to sayings I mean some men
steal with a gun and some steel with a
pen and it seems to just use that one it
seems to me that and I have a 30-year
career in corporate finance and I'm
lucky now to have been able to retire
and come to Yale where I'm I finished a
degree here I think I know where I speak
that wherever I speak when I say that
you can make these rules and laws as
complex as you want about behavior and
the fact is that these are very smart
people who will find a way to get around
whatever regulation however meticulously
crafted may come to exist when these
various studies have been completed and
additional rules are written so let us
not look to in my opinion the
capitalists to make this better let us
instead look to the regulator's we've
had wonderful regulators over the
decades that I can think of Volker I
think Arthur Burns going way back had my
admiration Arthur Levitt at the SEC
these were men of probity who knew it
was a game and they had to put their
full weight into it in order to push
against the capitalists who were finding
clever ways around the rules and when we
joke I think quite reasonably about men
like snow or O'Neill who were doing
comically irrelevant things at the time
you really have to say the regulators
have failed so i guess i would ask i
guess my question is would you comment
don't you think it's the regulators and
their intention that matters most at the
end of the day if they take the laws if
they take the rules seriously and fight
like hell they can keep the game
it's to a minimum I won't say I'll keep
them from happening but keep them to a
minimum would you care to comment I'll
comment on that just briefly somebody
asked me this question that our
conference that i don't remember exactly
was had something to do with central
banks and i said look you work in a
central banker you worked at the Federal
Reserve Board in this case who are the
super egg guys who are the super eight
crew at the Board of Governors and how
much are they paid compared to the
monetary economists where are their
offices you know do you know any of my
name it's a matter of giving people in
executing regulatory functions some
level of reward and some status for
doing that responsibly you know
otherwise it just becomes a bureaucratic
function so I guess I agree with you
thanks um I actually had a question that
was sort of the opposite of the last
question and I'm I was wondering how
much we can reasonably expect
legislation to mitigate these systemic
risks and especially given that I would
I guess I was wondering how much exactly
is risk an endemic part of financial
markets and so how could we possibly
conceive of reforming the financial
system in such a way that reduces the
possibilities of a subsequent downturn
especially when we consider things in
the long run and also look at sort of a
global picture about how financial
markets are increasingly intertwined and
whether legislation in the u.s. really
has the ability to impact sort of global
systemic issues I would just say that
the risk is not in systemic risk is not
an intrinsic risk it depends on the
design of the system and that in the
19th century we had periodic banking
crises that involved the compromise of
the money your money became worthless
you care then then we had we got the
national banking system which helped
reduce that any got the Federal Reserve
System which helped reduce that problem
so we made progress but still in 1933
your bank saving account was vulnerable
and lots of innocent people lost
everything because they had it in the
bank well they weren't insured and so
then we got deposit insurance now that
these examples of progress that we have
to keep fixing the system as it gets
more advanced new pet like the shadow
banking system appeared but I don't
think that the unregulated system is
going to work well it's our ability to
minimize systemic risk is a sign of our
progress and it's not something that we
have to keep doing okay last question
unfortunately let me go all the way back
you
I'd like to ask God Professor Shiller in
light of what mr. roat said what he sees
as the mandate like what the new mission
for the Fed or would it the mission
should include in terms of financial
stability directly referring to the
monetary the policy and what has gone on
and mentioned yourself just now the 19th
century banking or the bank crisis it
would just seem to me especially if we
again look at miss roaches career the
emphasis on Asia there there's a lot of
problems the dodd-frank act or the bill
the act that is uh again it is sort of
looking back it may or may not adjust
what's going forward but it seems the
real crux of the problem is a the
liquidity there's just so much out there
and there remains to be so much out
there we look at the Japan Japan the
talk of the carry trade that was once
that you know the huge yen carry trade
if you could just comment on your
thoughts of perhaps there's a real
solution with talking having the Fed
sort of curtailing the feds powers and
or really saying the feds mandate must
include some restraints in terms of how
much control they have over the monetary
policy the use of know the policy well I
think that it's implicit and things that
others have said here that a liquidity
site maybe we should have janji answer
this question we have a liquidity cycle
and it hasn't been recognized and it
doesn't seem to be fully understood by
the framers of this bill and so we need
regulators who are now we do in some
Sahara in Basel 3 is is involved with it
isn't a step for but maybe John can we
ask you to give your yeah June your what
the what how would you answer this
question this is John John accomplice
and the econ Department here yeah well I
would like to make a comment that has a
little bit to do with the question and
also it connects things everybody said I
think the idea that the failure if there
is a failure in the dodd-frank bill is
that it concentrates too much on
institutions and too little on the
systemic economy that's what Tom Cooley
said I think that's a very central point
and it's connected to the idea of what
Steve said that there should be you know
that the bubbles played a very big role
in the current crisis and have in
previous crises and maybe we should add
and this is may be connected to your
question maybe we should expand the
powers of the Fed to look after bubbles
as well as as their other two missions
of inflation and unemployment my
reaction to all that is that it's all
its i agree with almost all of that
except I I think one has to add one more
thought that monetary policy is just one
thing regulating the amount of money or
the interest rate it's just one tool and
we've been confined for some reason to
this one tool for far too long so i
think i would disagree with steve when
he says that it was the low interest
rates that caused our crisis and that we
could have avoided it all with better
interest rates many people say that I
just heard at Jackson Hole in fact a
Taylor of the Taylor rule he said the
only thing that went wrong we said you
know we followed the tail rule up to the
second decimal place until a few years
ago and then we got away from it that's
his rule where and now look what
happened to our economy and all we have
to do is go back to the Taylor rule so
steve is saying something a little bit
similar to that and I think that's I
think it's it's false far short of what
we need to do there's another variable
when you make a loan almost all loans
the vast majority of loans are
collateralized when you borrow money to
buy a house they can take your house if
you don't pay back so the amount of
money as a fraction the loan to value is
a fraction of the house that's a second
variable besides the interest rate it's
a far more important variable so what
caused bubbles I think is
too high loan-to-value if we didn't have
such a high loan-to-value wouldn't have
had the bubbles we could have played
around with the interest rate I don't
think that would have stopped the
bubbles it certainly didn't reverse the
bubbles when we got into the christ we
set the interest rate at zero and it
didn't solve our problems if you can't
get things to go back up by lowering the
interest rate I don't think that the
changing the interest rate is the you
know that one tool can't do everything
so in summary I think that I agree that
the Fed my own view that the Fed or this
council that Bob talked about so much
somebody should have the responsibility
of regulating systemic risks I think
part of that has to be looking at
leveraged loan to values what I mean by
that part of that has to be has to be
connected to looking at loan to value
something that we've just avoided doing
for far too long even though any
business anyone at Morgan Stanley would
tell you that loan to value is a
critical variable and yet we just ignore
it and we shouldn't do that and I think
now this office of financial research
they have the power to investigate what
and to uncover what all the loan to
values are how much do people put down
on houses how about to buy a inverse I
oh and they could study that you know
study that comprehensively and reduce
and reveal the numbers so sorry I've
talked a little bit too long but the
bottom line is I think that we have
another variable which is leverage and
that if the Fed were to use that it
could it could stabilize the economy and
these measures that have been passed in
Basel three in the dodd-frank bill which
basically says look at an institution
and sort of look at their debt to equity
ratio that's kind of like leverage
that's going to be a complete failure
because if you limit the debt-to-equity
ratios of a few banks or other financial
institutions the leverage will just move
somewhere else and if you limit the
overall debt to equity ratio of one big
institution they'll just they'll just
hold riskier securities where they don't
need to leverage as much so in fact
you'll force them to do even worse so I
think the answer that solution to our
problem has to lie in looking as Tom
said at economy-wide problems and not
institution bound problems so measuring
leverage
the level of what do you what's the loan
to value of particular things you're
borrowing against and once you recognize
that as a key variable and allow the Fed
or some other regulatory body to manage
that as well I think we can make
tremendous problems I don't think the
next crisis is going to be completely
different from the previous ones it's
going to involve leverage even the next
time thank you John I think you are
saying that there is still some hope for
macroeconomics who have in disgrace but
we still have some probably some work to
do unfortunately time is over so all
what remains is to say thank you to our
three great panelists and thank you for
attending